I want to go broader first before we
talk about Biogen specifically you know
as I just mentioned biotechs are getting
hammered the whole sector is in fact how
can things turn around for the industry
this year well look the there are always
cycles in in in biotech we had five
amazing years from 2010 through 2015 so
it's pulling back a bit now I don't I
don't think that's the end of the world
I think look the the what can turn the
sector around is really good news and
product news and you know both our
company and other companies have some
really exciting compounds in their
pipeline
I think if those move forward and
generate good data I think that will
bring some enthusiasm and some bounce
back into the sector well I know you've
got some exciting data on Alzheimer's
treatments and it's still as I
understand it on a smaller scale smaller
trials what can we expect from those
treatments George well look we did have
very exciting data with reported last
year in which we were able to show
removal of plaque from the brains of
Alzheimer's patients and that appeared
to correlate with a an improvement in
their in their cognitive function or
let's say a slowing of the decline of
their cognitive function that's a small
study it's not proof but it's very
suggestive and we're now in the
beginning a large Phase three program
that will hopefully demonstrate the
safety and efficacy of that compound if
if that bears fruit and we have a
compounds like this other companies also
working harder and Alzheimer's right
then it would mean either a slowing or
stopping of the progression of
Alzheimer's disease and that's an
exciting credibly exciting prospect know
that is a huge development and you
mentioned some of the other companies
who are working on this I mean how does
that how does your how does your data
stack up to some of the competition like
Eli Lilly who's also working on these
treatments Eli Lilly also has a program
in Alzheimer's disease it's it's hard to
tell I think we are very enthusiastic
about our data it's way too early to
make comparisons I believe but I can
tell you that we are quite compelled by
our data look I think this points to a
whole
part of the industry that maybe isn't
appreciated right now which is that the
the science and the medicine are
advancing to such a stage that you
actually can see a line of sight to
making a cure for Alzheimer's disease
for Parkinson's disease for ALS for
certain kinds of cancer that aren't
treatable right now so it's an
incredible exciting time in the industry
you know we had the Santa Fe Innovation
head with us yesterday and we asked him
about drug pricing as well because we
know price hikes have been a hot-button
issue so far in this election cycle as I
understand you're gonna be the
president-elect of the pharmaceutical
Lobby so how are you gonna address this
this whole issue of prices of drugs
going up too much yeah I think well
first of all I think there's a bit of a
misconception the the drug prices have
not increased faster than the cost of
healthcare as a whole but I what I what
I really would want to avoid is that
there would be some knee-jerk simplistic
solutions to what is actually a very
complicated issue and you know we've
been criticized other companies have
been criticized for raising drug prices
you know if you look back at what we've
done over the past 10 years we did raise
drug prices and the question is what did
we do with that money well we started
out with one product with MS and now we
have several that we've brought forth so
there's no question that MS patients are
better off now with several treatment
options than they were with one so we're
funding we're using the money from those
now to fund all the Alzheimer's research
so whatever happens we cannot have a
policy for drug prices that that
de-emphasizes and discourages that kind
of innovation or we we will slow the
flow of new drugs